oh okay great uh-huh so last lecture let
me just remind you from last time that
we were interested in agnostic allele
earning a single half-space f and the
domain was RN and for the time being we
were thinking about the Gaussian
distribution and if you remember no
matter what the underlying distribution
it is we've seen that it suffice is to
find a polynomial approximator for the
boolean function that you would like to
learn of a class of boolean functions
you'd like to learn and that means that
with respect to the underlying
distribution again in this case it's the
end variate gaussian if we want to learn
half spaces agnostic alee it suffice is
to show that you can always find a
polynomial approximator so in l2 so we
need to just construct a low degree p
such that p minus the sine of WX this is
our unknown half space w is unknown
squared is at most epsilon and since
we're working in gaussian space whatever
the let's assume all of the half spaces
or origin centered for the moment just
for simplicity but whatever the optimal
half space is out there with respect to
your data you can just rotate everything
and assume that the optimal half space
is 1 000 000 so this reduces this
particular problem which is I mean RN to
just a problem on the line with respect
to the univariate Gaussian density and
this expectation can be written as this
integral and then you know this this may
look slightly intimidating but we talked
about how once you have an orthogonal
family of polynomials with respect to
some distribution then it makes sense to
talk about the Fourier polynomial with
respect to that orthogonal family of
polynomial so we know just from kind of
basic facts I'll call it that the best
fitting degree d polynomial for this
particular function sine of X is the sum
from 0 to D of sea of IH of IX where c
of i is the Fourier coefficient of the
sine function so H of I is that I
lhermitte polynomial and c of i is the
Fourier coefficient of the sine function
this is the best degree D fitting
polynomial we even know an explicit
formula for the CIS it's it's sort of
easy to see that it's 2 times the
integral from 0 to infinity of the I
thermique polynomial x the Gaussian
density and as I said the hermite
polynomials are specifically constructed
to be orthogonal with respect to this
density so this is actually like this is
a very nice quantity to work with if you
look in a book on approximation theory
you'll see this probably see this term
floating around all over the place and
so it wasn't too difficult for us to
actually compute what the error of this
polynomial is again you have plan
charles equality so the error of the
polynomial of this degree d polynomial
is the sum of the squares of the
coefficients that you didn't choose so
it's the sum of the squares of its sum
of CI square from D plus 1 to infinity
and then you just need to estimate this
quantity which I'm sure is well known
before we did it but we did it anyway
and it turns out to be Big O of 1 over
the square root of D this means that if
you choose D to be Big O of 1 over
epsilon squared then this particular
integral here will be at most epsilon
yeah so you're learning with respect to
the Gaussian yes and you said sort of
without loss of generality this half
space goes through the origin yes but
that so if it shifted away that's not so
what that was a journey in a waiver if
it if it's if the threshold is not zero
you're right you know so so in this
calculation you can just include a minus
theta
and be just a little bit more dare phul
and everything will work out it's really
not a problem because you can still
assume that it's like the line x equals
1 but the rotational inertia fine but
it'll be shift a little bit so then you
end up shifting something inside the
integrand and it's it's no I understand
just saying these functions are now no
longer orthogonal with respect to I mean
though no no no there's no fire I mean
there's some fog enough respect to the
line that the mass but right now and
that's it but that's all that matters
because for any function on the line
doesn't matter what the function is as
long as it's the Gaussian density this
is still true so you'll get hitting the
old one over root d here I mean so
basically less yummy ass is near where
the X yes yeah okay yeah the animal to
choose okay good what you're getting in
red uniform examples right yes and now
you find the P that's already so all I'm
proving here is the existence of soompi
yeah but then the algorithm will be
polynomial regression so I'll take a
bunch of examples and I minimize
expectation of p minus y and then you
have to the fact that there existed p
that that's when doesn't imply that the
P you will find there actually does well
ah but we proved that two days ago the
fact that there exists a P that does
well whatever polynomial that you find
you will be almost as good as the one of
those rules in there close the case yes
yes so it's it always remember remember
we had the with we were doing when we
were doing element no no it's not
Occam's razor when we were doing elemen
we did that almost triangle inequality
mm-hmm to show that it was like eight
times a plus epsilon and so if you can
just by kind of direct calculation you
use the triangle inequality and subtract
this this p that you show of it that has
existed so the p that you find minus the
optimal p is going to be their
expectation is going to be small and
then the optimal p minus the function
you're trying to learn is also going to
be small by this thing right no no
outcomes razor here
I don't have any chocolates yes yeah
seems so you can snack you can eat my
knee I give you permission to you on
yourself okay and the last thing I
wanted to remind you of and so I don't I
don't think oh we might have to come
back to integration a little bit later
but the last thing I just wanted to
casually mention is the analogy between
writing a function as a linear
combination of parity functions when
your distribution is uniform on the q
and again if you're working with a
function in RN as long as this it's it's
square integrable with respect to the
Gaussian density in RN then it can be
written as an infinite sum or very
closely approximated by an infinite sum
of products of hair meet polynomials and
you'll have this plan jor-el equation so
I'm just trying to really nail home the
fact that though I guess some you know
when we were thinking about learning
with respect to Gaussian densities it we
started thinking about it we didn't
think it had anything to do with
learning with respect to the hypercube
you know because you have this nice
discrete Fourier analysis but then we
sort of realized that you know more
generally it doesn't matter that you
know whatever domain that you're working
in as long as there's some family of
orthogonal polynomials you're always
going to be able to do this
decomposition and you're always going to
have these kind of nice facts that we
use in the discrete setting namely Parsa
falls equation and best-fitting you know
degree depot no meals so so that was
just sort of very helpful to think about
and I'll come back to this in a bit okay
so uh
he said Lovelace the same so there the
whole yes yeah theory extends much more
uh yes yes so and that's why I asked
when he was talking about LCA if it fit
correspondent two gaussian space right
so I but I feel like kind of the the
approximation theory perspective here is
somehow different from the harmonic
analysis setting I don't know that I
feel like the perspective in the
techniques or the different know you
disagree okay solution through many
years ago is that many of these problems
you can get much better approximation if
you love rational functions oh yeah yeah
in fact I've used that to great effect
yes you do yes what do I need to see
this in machinery oh yeah yeah yeah it's
not a good example this I think goes
back perhaps late sixties is affected
well the absolute filter sign the
absolute value yeah yeah I just how how
often is it to Proxima know how well you
can do if you're not self yeah I've used
that fact and I think three papers so
the only issue with rational functions I
love rational fun will issue with
rational functions is that you know when
you want to find the best fitting degree
D polynomial there's this l1 polynomial
regression algorithm you can find it
finding like a low degree rational
function that minimizes something is a
non convex optimization problem and it's
horrible it's it's algorithmically
difficult to deal with
that's for another mini course okay so
yeah polynomials and Gao Xiang maybe
need to stay bound that oo of 1 over
square root beer by yes that's a very
faithful yes yes if you if you switch to
a different measure and different sets
of abnormal polynomials to get in
trouble because usually you don't have
as nice yeah exactly so impossible so
for example one thing that okay so one
other thing that we looked at was if the
distribution on the line was log concave
instead of gaussian and then your tale
becomes something like e to the minus t
rather than e to the minus t squared and
then actually figuring out what this
bound is we couldn't even quantitatively
come up with a bound we knew by
compactness that some there were some
bound that depended only on epsilon and
it was some function of epsilon and we
left it that way and then later we found
a survey that says you actually need to
choose D to be like 2 to the 1 over
epsilon squared so it's and if you were
here two weeks ago for the talk that I
gave on moment matching polynomials then
that was a sort of a another way of
trying to get at these quantitative
bounds without having to go through all
of this machinery and handle the log
concave setting which seems to be
difficult okay so um just looking ahead
for a second let's say we wanted to
learn f is the sign of W X minus data
and the sign of VX minus theta so it's
so it's the intersection of two half
spaces I don't know how to get this
machinery to work for such a function I
don't I don't know how to like you can't
project it to one dimension anymore and
I don't know how to do the integration
and so sort of
we talked to a lot of people who are
good at integration and they also could
not tell us how to how to handle this
case like I said they were more
interested in like cylinders and three
dimensions and and their their conic
sections then they thought maybe they
can do something but so what i want to
show you is a is a different proof of
this fact that there exists a pollen a
low degree polynomial approximator for
the sine function and this proof will
generalize very simply to more
interesting classes convex sets and
actually lead to a bound on all convex
sets
to do that I need to define something
called the noise stability of a boolean
function so how many people in here are
familiar with the noise ability of a
boolean function not everyone so good i
will definitely define them so first let
me define it for the cube this is the
probability when you choose X and then I
think I i weirdly iu z Z is an epsilon
perturbed version of X so you choose X
at random and then for each bit
independently of X you flip it with
probability epsilon and then you're
interested in the quantity what's the
probability that f of X does not equal F
of Z okay and there's also the Gauss we
can also define since we're talking
about Gaussian distributions and I want
to sort of cover both cases uniform over
the cube and Gaussian we can also define
the Gaussian noise stability of that how
many people have seen the Gaussian noise
debility event okay slightly fewer so
this is the problem again we'll fix my
veil right gee this is the probability
when you choose X according to the N
variate Gaussian and then why according
to an end very a gaussian and i'm going
to set Z to be 1 minus epsilon times X
plus square root of 2 epsilon minus
epsilon squared
why I'm going to look at f of X sorry G
X does not equal G of Z it's the same
idea i'm going to pick a random Gaussian
point I'm going to perturb that Gaussian
point by some other small it's much
smaller in magnitude Gaussian i'm going
to add up these points and i'm going to
look at the probability that G of X does
not equal G of Z so in both cases you
know I want you to think about this
quantity as sort of well what's the
probability that when I randomly choose
a point and then I perturb myself a
little bit but I end up on the other
side of the half space and in both cases
I want you to think about these
quantities think looking ahead as some
type of surface area if you're set has a
very large boundary then that should
somehow corresponding the correspond to
these being large
okay so why are we looking at these
everybody okay for the people who
haven't seen everybody okay with these
quantities okay so so claim is that and
out we can quantify this in a second but
low noise stability implies low degree
polynomial approximator so so what's the
relationship between the noise stability
of a function and a polynomial
approximator for that function so I want
to show that if you know the
relationship between kind of the
coefficients of a polynomial of f of x
times f of Z and then I think johan has
done this twice now but maybe this is
just slightly different we can look at
the Fourier expansion of these functions
I'm kind of skip some steps because I
think we've seen this before but
you know when you multiply all of these
out all of the terms that where s does
not equal T are going to be zero and
you're going to be left with terms where
s equals T
if working on this Sigma son same oh
yeah outside of st oh yeah row Thanks
let me just write this is little x done
this and this is little Z times so this
is the parody of the bits in x times the
parody of the bits according to s and z
and an individual bid is 1 minus 2
epsilon the expectation of just x 1 x z
1 or x item zi so this is
and then right so okay so you can see
some relationship now between the noise
stability of F and its Fourier
coefficients
and
the bottom line is that
some
s
is it most some constant times the noise
ability of that so the Fourier spectrum
of the fourier mass of coefficients on
degree greater than 1 over epsilon is
some constant bounded by the noise
ability of epsilon bet you can see this
by you can multiply the left and right
hand sides by 2 then you'll get 1 minus
something 1 is equal to the sum of the
squares of all the Fourier coefficients
pull some things out it's not too
difficult and then the upshot is that so
if the noise stability of F is some
let's call it h of epsilon then i was
right this wrong
then if then the sum of the squares f
hat of s squared is at most epsilon
where k here is one over the inverse
function of Epsilon okay so
it's not really important if you totally
understand this I mean just a high-level
idea is that you know if you want to get
a good bound on if you want to
understand how well the sum of the
squares of the Fourier coefficients are
concentrated it suffice it to get some
bound on the noise stability and what
we're going to prove is that the noise
stability of a half space is order
square root of epsilon so the inverse
function is going to be epsilon squared
and that means we'll have to choose K to
be 1 over epsilon square and that means
that if you know the sum of the squares
of all the coefficients beyond level 1
over epsilon squared are bounded by
epsilon and that will also imply that we
have a Fourier polynomial of degree at
most 1 over epsilon squared that
approximates our half space if we can
prove this found on the noise stability
of the linear threshold function okay
and the roughly the same thing is true
if instead of writing noise ability at
epsilon of F here I'd put a Gaussian
noise stability of epsilon of F you
would also get the same type of
concentration but instead of you know
fourier coefficient the for a polynomial
a polynomial over the cube you get
Fourier coefficients corresponding to
the hermite polynomials it's you get
exactly the same thing then so one nice
thing is that so everybody okay with the
relationship between oi stability and
approximation by low degree polynomial
don't seem keys instead of the size of
this would you get you get this little
square so instead of the size of s there
integers know you can still measure the
sot it's an index set so you can still
measure the size SS will be s will be an
element of a tuple of natural numbers
it'll just be the sum of the elements in
that tuple
okay and the nice thing so now that we
have this relationship what is the
Gaussian noise the Gaussian noise
stability of you know so the Gaussian
noise stability of a of a half space so
this is sine of X does not equal sign of
Z you can imagine in the plane choosing
a bivariate Gaussian where X and Z our 1
minus epsilon correlated gaussians then
you're interested in what's so I choose
a bivariate Gaussian where X and Z or 1
minus epsilon correlated and I want to
know what's the probability mass of this
region this is where the sine of X does
not equal the sine of Z this is also the
region where sine of X does not equal
sign of Z and this is a classical this
is cool this is a classical thing in
probability it's 1 over pi times the arc
cosine 1 minus epsilon this is
approximately square root of epsilon so
you'll get too thick immediately the
Gaussian noise since the Gaussian noise
ability of a half space is at most
square root of epsilon by this
relationship that implies that there's a
degree 1 over epsilon squared polynomial
hair meet polynomial that approximates
the half space and so that recovers you
know this proof that we did that kind of
looked at the integrals of how many
polynomials you sort of this falls out
immediately
and another nice thing is that we can
apply a the following trivial
observation that the Gaussian noise
sensitivity of F and G is at most the
Gaussian noise sensitivity of a plus the
Gaussian noise sensitivity of G that is
to just that's just to say imagine I
have the intersection of two half spaces
and I want to know what's the
probability when I choose a random point
and I perturb it that it flips into this
region well that's certainly at most the
probability that it flips into this
region or the probability that it I mean
the probability that flips over this
hyperplane or the probability that it
flips over this hyperplane so it's just
a Union bound so you get this
immediately and this implies that the
Gaussian noise sensitivity of the and
actually it's any function okay a half
spaces almost okay times square root of
epsilon and this will translate into an
end to the order K squared over epsilon
squared time algorithm or agnostic
learning any function of K half spaces
so this was this is nice I mean we came
up with this quantity Gaussian noise
debility it's easy to see why it's
corresponds to polynomial approximation
it's very well known that there's a very
well-known formula for the for a single
half space and if we want to generalize
this to intersections of half spaces
it's very very simple you apply a union
bouncing it's great now you can see if
you wanted to choose K to be very large
this will start this bound will will
start to become interest
uninteresting very quickly so I'll have
to talk about that in a second but I
wanted to prove to you that I wanted to
move back to the boolean domain and
prove to you that the boolean noise
stability of F is it most square root of
epsilon okay I mean I I sort of just
said oh well it's classical for in the
Gaussian case but for the boolean case
it's more delicate it's certainly not
classical so the noise ability at F
being order square root of epsilon the
first there's a very slick proof due to
Perez for this fact and I think actually
there was a weaker bound in benjamini
kailash roms that right maybe it wasn't
maybe was epsilon to the one-fourth
instead of square root of epsilon okay
something something like that ok and
then so park should go pull on came up
with a simpler proof so this is it's not
a very difficult proof but it's sort of
tricky to teach he had a simpler proof
and then there's a proof that's in a
dike a Nicholas ragavendra sir video and
tan it's a paper on the gottesman lineal
conjecture that i'm going to show you
that i think is even simpler as have
people seen this proof before no okay i
know you see
let me show you the proof it's slick
very slick what the easiest one i'm
going to show you this one I mean the
annoying thing I mean the nice thing in
the Gaussian case was that we could sort
of just assume that the half space is
sine of X I mean it's really really
simple and over the cube you know you
have these annoying integer coefficients
that are hard to reason about so you
know f is sign of really want to do this
right it's really slick so um oh I need
to define the influence of a rent of a
boolean function Roman I think we've
think most people have seen this this
from it I mean this is a super important
quantity in the analysis of blending
functions but it's introduced by Ben or
in the needle so this is the probability
that when I choose a random X and I flip
the ice bit of X that the function
changes sign and the sum of all the
influences I will calling the average
sensitivity up and I guess the one fact
that i'll need is that the average
sensitivity of F where F is a monotone
function is it most an episod and
variables is it most square root event
would you consider this a homework
exerciser okay I'll just say that if you
haven't seen this before that if F is a
monotone function then the ice fourier
coefficient so the ice so the
expectation of F times X I this is the I
fourier coefficient is exactly equal to
the I influence of F and since the sum
of the squares of all the Fourier
coefficients and is it most one then the
sum of the first n Fourier coefficients
can be at most root end so this is just
the key idea to showing this it's it's
it's not difficult so I guess what I'm
going to show you is that noise
stability is actually very very related
to average sensitivity and for a while
it sort of seemed like these were
fundamentally different quantities but
now I feel that the best way to bound
the noise ability of a boolean function
is really to just try and understand
what its average sensitivity is if you
unite epsilon go to zero yes yes it is
not roughly being another then cracked
okay so what I'm going to do so remember
we're interested in the probability that
when Z is a perturbed version of X f of
X does not equal F of Z okay now it
could so you know X and Z have some
joint distribution and I described it by
first using X at random and then
flipping each bit of X the probability
independently the probe with probably
Epsilon so instead I want to do the
following random experiment that will
result in the same joint distribution
first pic first pic exit random again
then pick a random partition of n2m sets
& M here is going to be 1 over epsilon
so pick exit random pick a random
partition of n then pick
are so pick one of these sets ass at
random and flip all the bits in s sub R
okay so all I'm saying is instead of
independently flipping each bit with
probability epsilon part randomly
partition the bits of X into these
buckets then pick a random bucket and
then flip all the bits in that random
bucket it's you're going to get the same
distribution
so
right so just just so I don't do this
wrong so alpha is going to be partition
and now Z is going to be a random this
is going to correspond to what you'll
see in a second then i'm going to set
let me say this this is why uniformly
random partitions and then pick a random
set and queen it's the same distribution
and speaking yeah
well think about it for a minute and
you'll convince yourself it's the same
then i'm going to set X I to be AI times
Z of alpha I y y sub l 5 and i'm going
to set zi to be AI x y sub alpha I with
the Arth bit flipped and I want to claim
that the noise stability at epsilon of F
is equal to the probability that I
choose a at random sorry forgot the most
important thing I'm going to choose a at
random alpha random Z at random are at
random that f of X f of X does not equal
F of Z so I'm claiming that this is like
your input string so this is some random
string a then i'm going to pick a
partition partitioning into buckets i'm
going to pick Y and I'm going to take a
I times y a alpha y alpha I so this is
literally picking a random string of
length n and then I'm randomly flipping
some of the other bits so it's ok I mean
X here is still uniformly distributed
over minus 1 1 to the N and Z is going
to be the same as X but one bucket is
going to have its bits flipped so these
distributions really are the same as
just a random X and it and a
perturbation you know I mean I mean
we're introducing these new kind of fake
variables that tell you which bits to
flip everybody ok with this so far maybe
you see how to do it already
so so this is just the probability again
over a alpha Y and our that f of a alpha
y is not equal F of a alpha got an X
here
but if of X is not equal to this motion
yeah y is not equal to a over white yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's what I mean thank
you right and then this I'll just I
could just I'm doing nothing I'm doing
nothing here now just writing things in
terms of an expectation of an indicator
function and then I'm going to pull in
my choice of our our could be one of em
things I'll explain this in a second so
this is the indicator function that
somehow like this is very simple this is
a very simple idea and so now it's like
tricky tour just like precisely right
down but now you can see that so I so
think about
you know for a fixed setting for a fixed
setting of a and alpha so for ya so for
a sixth setting of a and alpha I have
these new variables the wise but there
are only M of them and so for every
fixed setting of a and alpha the
function is still a half space but it's
a half space in just M variables so I
guess the way to think about it is we
have think about it is that if you're
simply reducing the original problem to
the problem of having a cube and you
have a half space and you are just
flipping one bit and so what I'm trying
I'm trying to annoy says it with the
with epsilon you are just looking at the
noise sensitivity with respect to just
changing once ordinate of X yeah honest
I'm trying to spell known that is square
root of M over right so I'm sure I'm
trying to reduce it to that I didn't
okay so i don't feel like i did a good
job of explaining it but i guess the
idea is you know you're now flipping
just all of the variables in one bucket
but you're flipping just one bucket now
where the variables have been
partitioned and you know each bucket has
sort of one variable associated with it
so flipping one bucket corresponds to
flipping just one variable and if you're
flipping one variable that's just the
influence of a half space which is a
monotone function and so this is going
to be 1 over m times you know this is
the sum of the influences of a half
space which is it most which is a
monotone function which is at most rude
amp and so this quantity is 1 over the
square root of n
this resume works not only for the sine
function but also for animal don't
function no so the subtlety here is that
for any fixing of a and alpha the
function must still be a half space or a
monotone fashion so it has to be in here
has to be a half space so it's it
requires some very weak closure property
does the supplement chose of the unique
way to function is the most noise
statement Jordan well majora majority is
the most at least I mean the least did
mostly among all the hospital and I
think this argument shows it actually
think direct calculation of a distance I
thought it was majority I thought
majority was ya know Maggiore is not the
most noise noise stable no no wait which
is the least but you want the least the
weighted module yes the least noise
stable hold on because the most noise
table is the constant function okay yes
later yeah he right but they may be
these have element make sure
but can I drew a picture like how I see
yeah yeah come on out traffic trickers
like so the way no way I'm seeing this
is that so here is like a religion cube
which is kind of I'm just throwing a fun
fun picture but then you FDA and then so
you have these partition and so this
partition like if you are looking at
like or possible through to the end base
of an to 2d and ways of partitioning it
well then that would give you like a
little like 2 to the N points here kind
of like this up like a sub cube it's
kind of like a parallelepiped sub cube
inside the cube and so you have the
original threshold function which is
still so now I'm just focusing on these
and now I'm everything over all these
pictures so on these what I have to see
is that just how many edges it cuts and
so we it's well known that the fraction
of the edges so inside this small cube
which is just again the a life sorted so
it's created from this fixed a those
Saudi so the number of edges it cuts is
just square root of M fraction and so
when you are averaging it out over all
these kind of patterns then that you
just get the arm the same
so one more thing you this says i think
i understand i'm just trying to
interpret everything we understand by
what what happens when you change over
your singing it seemed a bit frightening
in hearing there's no sensitivity we
have to understand what happens as we
change epsilon name of the bills cracked
his argument says that if you restrict
it to the opponent that you are coming
back to this situation right I can't
play that I see all the details at once
but the concept is really okay good you
know the the way I think about it is you
know instead of some of wixi you end up
making these new variables I mean sort
of just repeating what you said but you
have you know Z alpha I so you have so
now you know instead of randomly
choosing excise you could randomly
choose excise Z alpha I it's still a
random input and then instead of you
know instead of flipping an epsilon m of
these excise you could just flip this
one of these Z of the Z alpha eyes and
that's going to end up flipping epsilon
M of the variables and so it's just
what's the influence of of this function
when you just flip one of these new
zealand we get down to this smaller cube
it's a dictator function or an arbitrary
throat it's a linear thresh it's an
arbitrary linear threshold function but
now you're only you're just right you're
just interested in what's the problem
what's the influence the eye with
logarithms what's the influence and we
know that that's the total influence is
root em on em very so and it's uniformly
chosen among the coordinates of Z right
right exactly yeah so it's adding like a
ghosting variable here maybe when I do
this at one-thirty up say that better
okay okay okay I'll make a comment about
some people who said before yeah sure
talk about this intersection of two half
spaces and so yeah something that the
person is dead then you say that I'm
applying Justinian bounded all i care is
just how many inequalities define this
that's it put it Bradley these some
things so there was for example to just
stay here there was a lecture of James
Lee there is this whole concept that the
anakata spoof of all fake they have this
off a problem salesman can't do it well
Brandi whether the whole concept is you
have some pollito but somehow you prefer
if possible to connect it to a higher
dimensional if Brad we spoil it up in
higher dimensions determined by fewer as
fewer facets right this is there seems
to be some relationships a connection
between the two I wonder if there is
anything because right i mean the
complexity of proteome pay here depends
only on the number of defining fast
cracked so I wonder if the consensus
spread on panel I'll think about it
ok
I'll just say that this argument once
you have a bound on the noise stability
of a single half space again you can use
a Union bound to get bounced on the
noise stability of functions of half
spaces over the cube just again by
applying a Union bound and you can get
more results you can get similar results
for the Gaussian case as over the cube
okay but we wanted to do how good I saw
them so we wanted to do we wanted to
consider the case we wanted to do yet
more interest we wanted to learn yet
more interesting convex sets so we
didn't want to restrict ourselves to two
wedges you know we wanted to fix k and
arbitrary and convex set and we were
interested in you know can you find a
polynomial P so I'll say k of x is plus
1 when x is in the convex set then minus
1 when x is not in the convex set and
then i was interested in you know we
were interested in again you know can
you find a piece of tension minus of p
minus k of x squared plus an epsilon
this expectation let's say is with
respect to the Gaussian and we know now
it suffices to bound the Gaussian noise
stability of K so maybe we could get a
good bound on the Gaussian noise
stability of K but you know if K is an
arbitrary convex set it could be the
intersection of potentially infinitely
many hyper planes or half spaces and so
the balance that we get here are
uninteresting earlier in the lecture I
said you know you should think about you
know noise stability or the Gaussian
noise ability roughly as some notion of
surface area
and that leads me to the definition of
Gaussian surface area
because instead of analyzing the
Gaussian noise ability of a convex set
the characteristic function of a convex
set we're going to reduce Gaussian noise
stability to bounding Gaussian surface
area and then we'll be able to make use
of some results on Gaussian surface area
of various convex so what is Gaussian
surface area let's just start with what
is surface area the usual notion of
surface area this is the limit says also
goes to zero so the surface area of a
set K is the limit for any set K is a
limit of the volume of a delta blown-up
version of K minus the volume of K
divided by Delta so you can take no so
so Kate soup Delta here is you take
every point in k and you put a tiny ball
of radius Delta around it you look at
its volume you subtract off the volume
of the original convex set okay and you
divide by delta and gaussian surface
area
it's just going to be the same
definition except replace volume with
probability mass so it'll be the
probability mass of some set you know in
RN weighted according to the N variate
Gaussian density so by volume i really
need probability mass so that's the
definition of surface area there's also
if you're set is sufficiently smooth
there you can define it as a surface
integral
we integrate along the surface of your
convex set the Gaussian measure with
respect to some surface measure I don't
know if this but you can think about so
for example if you wanted to calculate
the Gaussian surface area of a half
space let's say at the half space x
equals 0 here's your half space no x
equals zero it's everything on we're
inside n into n dimensions yeah first
chord but I'm sorry I'm saying the
border of this half space is the line x
equals 0 then you can integrate the
Gaussian along this just integrate the
Gaussian measure along this line and
you'll get the Gaussian surface area of
a half space the constant fact it's 1
over root 2 pi oh yes or you can use
this formula yes and then you'll take
the derivative of the CDF yes exactly
and you Avett and its maximum point is
when the see PDF is at zero yeah what
was the question what is K data is the
data environment oh yeah yes all about
that why don't you divided by 2 delta
because like if i am taking a plane or
some things that I have done in this
direction and they're paying the
direction
yeah oh so you shouldn't see outside yes
yes you're taking like a shell around
the set it's you're taking like little
shells around the set you're looking at
its volume as it gets smaller and
smaller and just to contrast this with
normal surface area I'm not prepared to
enough not prepared to answer that
question he's looking at you idiot
bodies yeah these are convex or college
foods should go before the poison way I
don't want to get sidetracked on this
because I'm running out of time so okay
so if if you have a if you're looking at
the surface of a sphere you know as the
radius gets larger and larger it has
more and more surface area traditional
surface area but it's gal seein surface
area is getting smaller and smaller
because the boundary of the sphere is
getting farther and farther into the
tail of the Gaussian and you can bound
the Gowans Gaussian surface area of
spheres it turns out that the sphere of
maximal Gaussian surface area is not the
one centered at the origin it's slightly
offset because you want sort of as much
of the surface of the sphere near the
origin of the Gaussian as possible and
these calculations are a little delicate
but they're doable and what's
interesting about you know the main fact
that we use about Gaussian surface area
and it's implicit in the works of LeDoux
and busy a is that the Gaussian noise
sensitivity of a function is at most
root pi times root epsilon times a
Gaussian surface area
some of that not you know not totally
surprising but yeah I'm abusing notation
here so f is the characteristic function
of maybe I should just write k and I
said that k was the characteristic
function of the convex set he's also
equality from the other side oh that's
more subtle that's not always true
that's a more complicated question and
it's not clear so then once we had you
know once you have this relationship you
can really start you know doing some
good literature searches so it turns out
that Keith ball and also put idea
nazarov prove that for any convex set
set K the Gaussian surface area of K is
at most n to the one-fourth
and so you know when you under when you
move from Gaussian surface area to go
see annoy stability and then back to a
polynomial approximation and then to the
learning result this will imply that you
can agnostic Lee learn any convex set in
time n to the square root event so you
actually get something a non-trivial
learning algorithm for any convex set
yes a you look at a sphere of a
sufficiently large radius and you look
at an exponential number of random
tangent hyper planes to this fear the
body is the intersection of these
randomly tangent hyper planes to the
sphere
since it's politically to goodbye
somehow bounding the sphere is lots of
yeah yes yep and then also there's a
result due to nazarov that says that
this is very interesting that if you
have the intersection of K half spaces a
Gaussian surface area is it most square
root of log K well some constant times
square root of log K so this is remember
when we were using the Union bound to
sort of found the Gaussian noise
sensitivity of an intersection of K half
spaces you know you've got something
that depended on k if you use this fact
about Gaussian surface area you get
something that depends on root log K
that's very interesting to me at least
that you know it's a statement about
sort of the probability that you lie
within some boundary of the intersection
of K hyper planes and that when you
choose a random point that you lie
within the boundary of the intersection
of K hyper planes and it doesn't at all
I mean it's a much has a much much much
better dependence on k than I mean has a
much better dependence on much improved
dependence on K so a very interesting
fact so fearful just stand to reason the
absence of those are beautiful
because here he said it's an exponential
number of hyperplanes Hoffs texts yes it
is an exponential lafortune yeah just if
I just want to interpolate between these
tools i would guess that means of the
absolute or do they know that this is
time yes that should be perhaps for food
just to make it known as it now this is
a tight stuff yeah for example for the
cute it's attained by the cube the solid
view
and so I guess you know what I didn't
state i should say more generally if s
is a bound on your gaussian surface area
then you can learn diagnostically learn
the concept class in time n to the order
s square I should also point out that in
the boolean case so if F isn't and of K
half spaces and we're working over the
cube so none there is a notion of
boolean surface area but I haven't found
it to be useful in any sense but Daniel
Caine just proved like last month i
think that the noise stability of an
intersection of k half spaces is the
most some constant times root log k
times square root of epsilon so he also
managed to get this bound and the proof
is like three pages of elementary
calculations
which is really annoying because I
worked on it for a long time but not
surprisingly you know these bounds
matchup of two plies results is like
this um it will imply the learning
result in Gaussian space yep I don't
know if it will apply that the Gaussian
surface area is real of Cain can you do
these transfers with these invariants
principles you yeah yeah you can yeah
yes you can this is how easy is doing
good no no no if you want to transfer
this if you want to say oh well you know
since the Gus the Gaussian noise
stability is something like root log k
and then I'm going to apply an
invariance principle and hope that
that's true on the cube it only works
for functions on the cube that are
sufficiently regular it's not going to
work for all half spaces on the cube so
that's one issue and also he like I
don't consider the invariance
applications of the invariance principle
of elementary so you know he uses like
convexity of functions yeah it's pretty
slick
okay so i guess the last thing i'll have
time to talk about but I'm glad that's
cool efficient yeah so what about
learning in the sense that there is a
complex woman and get uniformly random
points from within the condo so once the
sufficiently living there won't be able
to recognize them what's the purpose
could be away from the bottom to
recognize it in because we have a margin
but is this bindle yes and you can do
something I mean I mean what you what
you what you want to do there depending
on what the margin is first apply a
random projection into a load lower
dimensional space and then we can talk
about it later you can do things yeah
okay so I wanted to kind of combine all
of these ideas and with a result of
santosh for learning on learning convex
sets
actually I should say you know
intersections okay half spaces and this
result of sent osha's will not work in
the agnostic setting so it's so there's
no noise but the idea is the following
let's just look at a wedge against at
the intersection of two half spaces so
we're an RN but we're trying to learn
the intersection of just two half spaces
so here are the normals have spaces now
if you could somehow identify subspace
spanned by the normals so if you could
identify the two-dimensional space which
is the space sub spanned by the normals
then what could you do I mean what's the
first thing you would do in this
learning problem you take all of your
examples you would project them into
this two-dimensional space and now I'm
in r2 so once i'm in r2 there are lots
of thing i could do I could use brute
force search or you could apply our
algorithms and instead of an N here you
could replace it with two or whatever
dimension that you've projected down to
okay so it's you know identifying the
subspace that spanned by these normals
is is you know it'd be fantastic if you
could do that I mean it really
simplifies the problem
and here's an idea as to why you should
be able to identify the subspace spanned
by the normals okay again I'll think of
a wedge okay so remember we're in RN but
we're trying to learn the intersection
of two half spaces okay so consider like
you know we have we're getting all of
these points they're drawn from a
Gaussian distribution and let's just
look at the positive positively labeled
points
so summer label- summer label positive
just draw a lot of them and just look at
the positively labeled points in a
direction that's irrelevant namely one
that sort of goes through the whiteboard
in out this way what is the variance of
all of the positive points in this
irrelevant direction same as the normal
it's one I mean because in an irrelevant
direction I mean you just have a
Gaussian density here it's not at all
bounded by any of these hyper planes but
if you look at the direction that's
relevant then what you might hope is
that the variance in a direction that's
relevant of the positive points is
bounded away from one so this this is a
conjecture that we had that for every
direction every relevant direction w the
expectation of w x squared is bounded
away from one what is it clear that it's
less than 0 yeah good question actually
it's uh it's intuitively it seems like
it should be the case I think but when
you actually sit down and try and prove
it it's quite hard and that's what I'm
going to talk about in a second but it
is true that for directions that are
relevant when you restrict to the
Gaussian and that in that direction that
the variance does decrease well there's
you know let me get to it you'll be
excited by the theorem I'm going to tell
you so the conjecture is that for every
direction this is bounded away from one
and in fact this is bounded away from
one by a noticeable amount that you can
detect by random sampling okay
so let's assume this is true then let's
assume the conjecture is too true how do
we identify the relevant subspace sorry
yeah i like to call it pca but you take
all of your positive points and center
them and then if you compute all of the
eigenvectors and the eigenvalues the
largest eigen values will correspond to
eigenvectors of maximal variance and the
smallest eigen values will correspond to
directions of smallest variants okay so
this is we can apply SVD pca to the
covariance matrix I guess if you know if
you haven't seen this before if you pick
a direction you and you you look at you
transpose Sigma you where Sigma is the
covariance matrix this is going to be
the variance in direction you and Sigma
is symmetric to covariance matrix so the
largest eigenvalue and eigenvector will
correspond to the direction of maximal
variance so that's why computing the
eigenvectors and corresponding eigen
values will tell you what the largest
what the directions of maximal variants
are and then so after you've computed
all of these eigenvectors you can look
at the ones that are bounded away whose
eigenvalues are bounded away from one
and those are going to precisely
correspond to the directions that are
relevant and then you can just work in
that subspace spanned by those relevant
directions okay so
so centers prove this conjecture is true
and person I don't know why we couldn't
prove it was true but I do know why we
can prove this true we were trying to
prove something stronger but I told this
conjecture psych offhand that after
centos proved it was true and wrote his
paper I offhandedly told this conjecture
to Raghu and Mecca and in like five
hours he had sent me like a reference
that completely proved the conjecture so
he wasn't there when I needed him but I
will show you I will show you the
theorem that he found and it's a theorem
due to caffarelli and it's a
generalization of one of the brass camp
leave inequalities and Marya this is
gonna so this is um this is going to be
exactly you know what you what you were
asking ok so so I'm going to let new be
the uniform distribution over a convex
set over any convex set so you can think
of sampling a bunch of positive examples
and that distribution corresponds to new
and Phi again will be the n variate
Gaussian
and I'm assuming that the mean like
everything centered around the origin or
the mean of all of your points is mean
of all of your distribution's here at
zero so what caffarelli proved is that
for all know i just well yeah I mean the
Gaussian is it's going to be and this is
the standard end variate Gaussian and
new is going to be centered and so what
caffarelli proved is that for all convex
functions sigh expectation with respect
to new obses sorry i guess i should say
and for all w RN the expectation of sy
of w
let's say why it's drawn from New is it
most the expectation with respect to the
Gaussian five WX and this is really
inner product here so for example if you
choose sigh to be a function Phi of Z to
be the function Z squared then you'll
get that the variance in any direction
when you the vit so the variant this the
variance of any direction of your
positive points is it most the variance
in that direction of the Gaussian which
is something we sort of already knew I
mean it's at most one does the statement
of the theorem make sense turn not quite
so okay so so you have one distribution
and it's just you know uniformly chosen
points according to the convex body so
that's like you take your set of random
examples labeled positive that this is a
sample from that distribution know so
you have the Gaussian distribution
you're getting randomly label you're
getting examples drawn from the Gaussian
summer label- summer label positive the
positive ones induce a uniform
distribution induce a distribution over
this convex body this is the ghost this
is the Gaussian measure right restricted
to the convex body and then renormalized
and you need to be centered around the
origin I don't know so why do you like
it just be anything any sense yeah where
you said something about yeah there's
another term here that I didn't want to
write so I just
come 0 when things are centered so look
we get the full and equal no yeah it's
minus except it is you subtract off the
the the mean of the distribution oh the
center of mass yeah you see you subtract
off the center of mass okay this make
sense these beautiful sorry so it's the
same Gaussian centered at the origin now
just Reese restricted to points with it
rees khel to within points of the
context body yeah what stops you from
sort of being in the direction where w
is very large and and I don't some
normal what stop I can make you tiny
it's a point to you of the body whatever
you are the body of you and okay it's
it's all located somewhere word you've
rescaled to renormalize this improve the
century go oh that's not written
anywhere III said it sorry motion food
so okay again so what's the center of a
convex body so just as a sensuality yeah
the center of mass according to the
Gaussian distribution according to the
Gaussian distribution yeah all right
yeah sorry that's what this I guess I
should have written this annoying term
but
so let's say I'll let's say that every
bounding hyperplane all right yeah every
bounding hyperplane is it distance at
most be from the origin okay i can i can
assume this because if if the bounding
hyperplane i mean we can assume that be
something like square root of log n if
the bounding hyperplane is like very far
from the origin then you might as well
just assume that it's not there and then
i'm going to define this function so the
question is how to apply this this
contraction inequality yeah boy this is
vehicles over so if I think just as you
say the Z squared but sort of you know
in the direction of W so if I stick my
body I'm sorry three strips that exactly
the direction of W rescaling the
Gaussian is going to give me relatively
speaking a lot more variance in that
direction then just the nice fat gal
seeing the unrestricted Gaussian so when
you say and can you ask your question
again I'm saying it doesn't seems
unreasonable so so if I if I let my set
whatever it is be the line actually just
take the long yeah yeah let's just take
the line let's just look at the real
line okay and now I want it so you know
the Gaussian has variance of one on the
line and now I want to look at the
Gaussian restricted to some interval on
the line well around the origin well I
mean no this this this theorem will hold
for any interval on the line
I don't I don't need to i don't need the
restriction to be around the origin
there is a there's a term and the
theorem here that will will take care of
that but this i'm claiming that the
variance of the Gaussian restricted to
this interval is about is less than one
even if your way out in the tail would
you rescale this to be probably i'm
going to rescale it to be a probability
distribution yes but i'm still claiming
that the variance of this probability
distribution scaled and renormalized in
this interval is less than 1 i'll do it
doesn't think so why are you talking
about variance you have a convex
function how does vary us coming to the
future yes I can talk I can oh you see
I'm sorry sciences yeah yeah okay let's
talk about it after it later okay okay
so let me just show you let me just show
you that I mean the whole trick here is
what size you should choose so you want
to choose sigh on the interval minus B
be sigh of Z should equal Z squared and
then so
and then outside minus B to B when you
hit point be here you want to choose
sigh instead to be a tangent plane
okay and so what I wanted to claim or
maybe we can talk more about afterwards
is that when you choose this sy on the
left hand side of this equation you're
going to have exactly the variance in
direction w of this distribution
restricted to the positive examples of
the convex set and on the right-hand
side you're going to have remember when
we were integrating just x squared with
respect to the Gaussian you get one but
now we're integrating something that x
squared dominates and so when you
integrate it you'll get something like 1
minus e to the minus B squared you'll
get something slightly less than 1 so on
the left-hand side I'm claiming you get
variants in Direction W of your positive
sample points and on the right hand side
I'm claiming you'll get something
noticeably less than 1 and this will be
enough to kind of run PCA and identify
the relevant variables okay so
I'll just up here and we can talk about
it more afterwards